Let's go next to our caller from the five
five nine area code.
Who's calling today from 555 nine?
Hi, David.
This is Nick from L.A., Nick from L.A..
What's going on here?
It's hot.
They're very hot.
Oh, yeah, it's been pretty hot around there.
One 18, one 21.
I was in Woodland Hills.
Wow.
Yeah, I'm a fan of your show.
I actually know you from.
It was like a long time ago.
I have about eight years ago when you had
an interview with Anonymous, OK.
And there's lots of protest to search.
Yes, I have two.
I have two quick questions.
You know, my twin I wanted to know if I wanted
to know if it was possible for Lucy Donald
Trump to go left on some policies.
Do you think he would actually do that in
order to try to win reelection?
I don't know that there's anything Trump can.
I mean, we've got seven weeks and more and
more people are going to be voting early and
absentee.
So a lot of people in four weeks, a lot of
people will have voted.
I don't know that there's time now for Donald
Trump to get any policy done.
I mean, he can he can throw some executive
orders together if he thinks it will help
him.
But I think it's too late for policy for Trump.
I a major of.
One last question.
Let's see if Joe Biden, Windsor wins the election.
And let's say that he tried to impose like
a mass policy.
But then do you think, like any of the Trump
supporters or any conservatives might actually,
like, follow by?
I just don't see that happening.
I'm sorry.
You said if Joe Biden tries to implement what
kind of policy?
Like like a mass policy, like a like a mandatory
mass policy for her for every state.
Are you saying meth like crystal methamphetamine?
I'm trying to.
I'm just not sure I understand.
No, no, no.
Mass, mass.
Mass.
Our policy.
Oh, my God.
I thought you said I'm a math policy.
Listen, here's the deal here.
Here's the deal with that.
So ultimately, it's up to governors.
It's unclear whether legally that the president
can make everybody have to wear a mask, because
a lot of those decisions are just state level
decisions.
But if it if it's logical to say everybody
should wear a mask for the next two months
because of what's going on, I think Joe Biden
will suggest it.
And I think most governors will do it.
And you know what the political fallout is?
I don't know.
I think on that issue, I think if it's the
right thing to do, Biden will do it.
Awesome.
Thank you so much.
If you don't mind, I'd like to give like a
quick shuttle before I go.
I really appreciate it.
OK.
Like, this is like the shout out to colliculus
cause she felt so Kolinsky OK.
I do.
And the writing on the Hill, there was two
or three other ones I usually listen to every
every day.
So I do appreciate it very much.
All right.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate the phone call.